♪ ♪
>> Laura: WE ARE UNVEILING A
NEW FEATURE TONIGHT ON
"THE ANGLE."
IT GATHERED THE CHILDREN AROUND
THE TELEVISION BECAUSE IT'S TIME
FOR READING WITH KJP.
♪ ♪
>> HOW CONFIDENT ARE YOU THE
PRICE HIKE WILL TAMP DOWN
INFLATION?
>> HERE'S WHAT I WILL SAY IS
THAT WE UNDERSTAND WHAT
AMERICANS ARE GOING THROUGH.
AS YOU KNOW, THIS HAS BEEN A
PRIORITY BRINGING DOWN
INFLATION.
>> WHY IS THE PRESIDENT ASKING
OIL COMPANIES TO DRILL MORE HERE
IN THE U.S.?
>> LET ME JUST GIVE YOU A LITTLE
BIT OF A RUNDOWN OF WHY WE ARE
HERE.
>> OIL REFINERIES STILL HAVE NOT
BOUGHT REFINERY CAPACITY BACK TO
THE PRE-PANDEMIC LEVELS.
AT THE SAME TIME COME UP
PURITANS INVASION OF UKRAINE
PUTS PRESSURE ON GLOBAL SUPPLY
AND
puts pressure on global supply
GAS PRICES HAVE GONE UP BY
NEARLY $2 SINCE BEFORE THE
INFLATION.
>> DO YOU THINK THE WHITE HOUSE
WILL BE CONCERNED ABOUT HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY?
>> WE KNOW HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
IS A CENTRAL CHALLENGE FOR
FAMILIES.
THE PRESIDENT UNDERSTANDS THAT
AND THIS IS WHY HE PUT FORWARD
THE HOUSING SUPPLY ACTION PLAN.
♪ ♪
>> Laura: WELL, ACCORDING TO
THIS WHITE HOUSE, JOE BIDEN HAS
NOT JUST SAVED THE U.S. ECONOMY,
HAS US HUMMING BUT WHAT'S THE
REALITY?
SECOND QUARTER GDP GROWTH WILL
BE, WAIT FOR IT, 0.
THE PHILLY FED INDEX SLIPPED A
CONTRACTION TERRITORY SINCE
LOCKDOWN.
THE DOW WAS DOWN SHARPLY ON